une augmentation salariale tout de suite
de 2000 euros pour l'ensemble des
salariés le SMIC et un départ on
retraite à 50 ans à temps plein c'est ça
le revendications on ne peut pas tuer
des ouvriers derrière des quais et les
bonnets alors mange jusqu'à 70 ans alors
justement vous pose la question aussi
pour vous de vous pour ou contre la
retraite à 64 ans et qu'est-ce que vous
pensez des propos de Mouloud merci
d'être là merci beaucoup alors on vous
entendez vous savez nous aussi on donne
la parole à tout le monde et voilà
toutes les idées sont plutôt les
bienvenus et si elles sont contredites
ou argumentées donc voilà vous pour vous
poser la retraite à 50 ans alors on va
vous êtes vous êtes très jeune vous avez
quel âge
dans une semaine je souhaiterais mes 49
ans
ça concerne voyons pas déjà vous vous
êtes voilà alors vous vous êtes pour la
retraitement et qu'est-ce que vous
répondez à Mouloud qui va vous répondre
après alors moi j'entends donc comme
j'ai dit si des économistes qui disent
qu'il faut absolument rallonger le temps
de travail voilà donc 64 ans moi je
pense que c'est bien on vieillit on
vieillit beaucoup donc moi je vois ma
grand-mère elle a 93 ans globalement ça
fait plus de 30 ans qu'elle touche la
retraite donc je me dis qu'avec des gens
qui vieillissent on va avoir un problème
de financement et donc je suis pour
cette réforme en plus j'ai l'impression
que malgré tout il y a des choses qui
sont bien le montant on va pas on va pas
donc il y a des trucs qui me semblent
bien donc je pense qu'on est obligé de
se mettre au travail d'autant plus que
nos voisins européens tous rentrent dans
le travail plus plutôt que nous et par
plus tard que nous donc je vois pas
pourquoi il y aurait une exception
européenne et donc voilà alors on est 50
ans oui je pense que c'est une sorte de
petite punchline effectivement vous avez
du succès tout le monde vous mercredi
parce que c'est un peu spectaculaire
mais je pense que dans les faits c'est
impossible de financement de financer ça
alors qu'est-ce que vous répondez
tout simplement que je veux dire que
j'ai appris que j'ai fait le buzz
c'est étonnant parce que c'est une
vieille revendication je sais juste de
préciser que je suis syndicaliste je
suis pas politicien
on revendique toujours
pour améliorer nos conditions de vie et
de travail c'est mon rôle c'est pour ça
que j'ai été élu c'est pour ça que je
continue à apporter les revendications
des salariés
j'essaie juste de revenir
préciser parce que je crois que la vidéo
bon ils ont pris juste un extrait
qu'est-ce que j'ai dit pour être concret
nous les salariés en fait on travaille
dans le monde de la logistique
Geodis
filiale à
c'est un poids lourd de la logistique
derrière c'est que quand je parle
d'équerre à la fin peut-être ça parle
pas beaucoup de gens il faut rester dans
le oui parce que les quais c'est quoi
sur une plateforme c'est une fourmilière
où les salariés bah en fait il se situe
à la tâche et là c'est pas pour faire le
buzz c'est la réalité donc pour vous
c'est pour vous quand vous avez dit que
ma grand-mère
elle a de la chance et tant mieux là
j'essaye d'être juste terre à terre
quand on voit les statistiques et
surtout les études montrent que la vie
d'un ouvrier allait sept ans moi qu'un
cardan ça c'est un fait on peut pas le
protester c'est la pénibilité bien sûr
et là j'y viens
dans notre monde d'ouvriers ou ces
salariés qui sont derrière les quais bon
on les a cachés parce que personne porte
leur voix
on porte des charges lourdes
on travaille de nuit on décalé
j'emporte des charges très très lourdes
des palettes portez des MD la matière
dangereuse des animaux vivants
et travaillant en décalé de nuit
pour un salaire de misère
ça c'est juste de faire une petite
parenthèse en sort de cinq semaines de
grève pour revendiquer ça a l'air
descend malgré la pénibilité déjà les
salariés sont mal payés mais bien sûr
qu'on a beaucoup de sujets
mais quand j'entends ça j'ai au début
j'ai cru que c'est un sketch des
Inconnus tercio premier deux yeux très
haut évidemment que la pénibilité et les
gens on l'a vu chez Total qui perdent
huit ans d'espérance de vie parce qu'il
respire des trucs dégueulasse ça c'est
un cas par pour le reste on le garde
dans la réforme pour le reste pardon
faut être juste logique la force d'un
pays c'est sa démographie ça veut dire
qu'il faut des jeunes l'Allemagne est en
train de perdre sa place des leaders
parce qu'il a trop de vieux il faut des
jeunes effectivement aujourd'hui la
plupart des gens aujourd'hui
vont avoir une vie inactive
quasiment à leur vie active donc ceux
qui sont contre comme Raymond c'est ceux
qui sont en train de dire à leurs
enfants à ton fils tu auras rien toi je
vais t'expliquer ce qui va se passer si
un jour tu gagnes 5000 balles dans
tonnes de brut dans ta vie ton fils
c'est 5000 il lui restera 2003 pourquoi
parce que tout partira aux impôts et aux
retraites parce que la France est
endettée et que la France est en train
de rentrer dans une crise totale donc je
te le dire c'est ce qui va se passer
c'est ce qui va se passer et donc je
vais vous dire quelque chose parce que
pardon je l'économise quand même un
petit peu j'en ai fait 6 ans lui dire
quelque chose en ce moment ce qu'on fait
c'est qu'on est en train de vivre sur
les années 58 quand on a créé en 1958
voilà
donc on vit sur les Trente Glorieuses
comme s'il est encore dans les années 60
c'est fini la Constitution c'était en 58
on est en 2020 faut changer et si le
gouvernement avait été honnête il aurait
mis la retraite à 67 ou 68 ans pour que
la France pour que la France ne coule
pas ils y vont par étape mais ne rêvez
pas la prochaine retraite ne rêvez pas
la prochaine réforme c'est 67 je vous le
dis sinon on est mort
je suis pas je suis pas d'accord avec
avec vous tu peux me tutoyer bah merci
bon en fait les stats montrent que
au-delà de 60 ans il y a un actif sur
deux
dans mon monde des ouvriers
à 50 ans
mais foutu à tous ce qu'on appelle les
les troubles musculaires
musculo-scolytiques les PMS ça c'est dit
je suis d'accord j'ai une bonne partie
des collègues
parce que moi je suis pas détaché je
travaille toujours
sans fait opérer soit du dos soit des
épaules Monsieur Personne remet en
couple quand on est à l'ouvrier c'est
très dur de vieillir mais elle est pas
là la question
ok ça c'est une annonce comment on fait
non j'ai pas dit ça je n'ai pas dit ça
on a dit que ça c'est une vieille
revendication ouais je suis un
syndicaliste on se bat vous voudriez
de finir bien j'essaie juste de
juste
spéciaux c'est pour ça que les salariés
d'avant sont battus voudriez le quand on
parle qu'on a dénigré les régimes
spéciaux et on monte les salariés les
uns contre les autres
les régimes spéciaux il a été fait pour
compenser par rapport à la pénibilité
par exemple j'imagine que toi tu peux y
aller jusqu'à 70 ans c'est ton choix
tant mieux
mais pour un salarié on va pas l'obliger
allez maintenant 64 ans mais avec 43 ans
de nuitée
43 ans pour être simple on va pas
rentrer dans le détail
le taquin 64 ans tu peux partir mais si
tu as pas l'ensemble de tes trimestres
tu restes je perce 67 ans voire 70 ans
et on comprend tout ça mais bien sûr
aucun pays c'est très simple il faut que
normalement ta retraite soit à peu près
maximum de la moitié de tes années à
travailler
en galère
tu me dis que nos voisins ils ont choisi
leur modèle social ok il y a pas de
problème il faut aller jusqu'à 60 67 ans
et les Sims que c'est correct à peu près
la moyenne moi j'aimerais bien que tu me
répondes mais j'espère que tu sois
honnête
le salarié à 55 ans
on va commencer par 50 ans il est foutu
on va le licencier il est inapte il peut
pas travailler
on l'a viré on l'a on va le mettre au
chômage
comment tu fais pour lui alors déjà
on rentre dans la précarisation déjà
ouvrier c'est dur physiquement mais je
veux dire un truc très simple dans le
monde où on est nous déjà nous à 50 ans
si demain je suis au chômage et que tu
veux retrouver un boulot dans une
société c'est déjà aussi très compliqué
le sélectionnement personne te pose pour
te former
même pas on va voir comment on peut
financer ah ben j'adorerais l'entendre
parce qu'on est un pays un pays quand
même riche alors nos jeunes on leur
demande de faire de plus en plus
d'études parce que malheureusement les
gens qui ont de l'argent s'exportent
c'est pourquoi parce que
je t'explique
je vais t'expliquer pourquoi un gamin
qui va faire Satan études tu lui
expliques que dans quelques années s'il
gagne 10000 balles il va lui rester 4000
parce que tout le reste il le donne pour
payer des retraites d'argent que lui ne
verra jamais et de gens qui ne connaît
pas et tout le reste c'est des impôts
qu'est-ce qui fait il va se barrer donc
ces gens-là on en a besoin bah si il va
se barrer
en fait c'est une vie donc c'est une
vieille c'est une vieille bataille de
jeune le capital contre le travail merci
Cyril donc ça veut dire qu'on demande
aux gens de faire de plus en plus
d'études pour avoir des bacs plus 5 et
on demande à la retraite de baisser
qu'est-ce qui juge c'est mathématique
comment on fait et pour l'envoyer est-ce
qu'il a fêté ses études comment est-ce
que le voyez il a fait ses études parce
que il par trimer à 20 ans ou 21 ans si
il a de la chance il passe d'une
précarisation et une autre d'un taf à un
autre oui alors juste pour ta gouverne
le 31 décembre 2022
nous avons fêté l'anniversaire d'un
collègue qui avait 70 ans alors lui
Mouloud il était 60 ans 70 ans on a
soufflé ses bougies 70 ans pourquoi
parce que il a eu un parcours chaotique
durant durant sa vie donc il a pas
cotisé ah c'est de trimestre pour avoir
une retraite digne sans bien d'accord
donc il était obligé
de trimer jusqu'à 70 ans mais moi
j'aimerais bien qu'on l'invite le débat
il est là de société j'ai pas dit parce
que la façon de son contexte 50 ans
terminé pour faire le buzz non c'est une
vieille revendication on dit pour les
travailleurs on a compris monsieur le
problème et ouvriers c'est très dur il
porte des sacs mais franchement pardon
je suis le premier à le dire
on a compris votre problème ouvrier
c'est très dur c'est à 50 ans on est
fini mais on ne comprend pas on ne
comprend pas derrière aucune prise en
compte de ces avec ces réformes qui est
contre la avec cette réforme il y aura
aucune prise pour la retraite à 64
parce que lui il est contre aussi
pourquoi moi je suis pas le maintien du
statu quo 62 ans il y a une exception
française et effectivement je suis aussi
pour Mouloud pour les ouvriers il faut
descendre c'est pas possible que des
ouvriers est une retraite quasiment
mortifère c'est à dire que quand ils
prennent leur retraite à taux plein il
leur reste très peu d'années il y a des
régimes spéciaux pour la pénibilité et
il faut les conserver quand ils disent
50 ans pour moi c'est pas une punchline
c'est ce qu'il pense c'est des palettes
très lourdes c'est éreintant ces gens
ont le droit de profiter de leur
retraite donc je suis je suis pour les
50 ans pour les 50 ans et la retraite à
50 ans à 50 ans pour les ouvriers et
qu'on conserve à 62 ans comme
aujourd'hui très bien et alors on arrête
alors demande à tous les médecins c'est
aussi demain à tous les médecins
d'arrêter surtout les progrès de la
science ma grand-mère est dans ta 96
aujourd'hui les personnes inactives
vivent 35 ans retraitement 45 ans les
experts vous contredisent le problème
c'est qu'il va encore me dire 100% des
psychiatres arrêtez aucun expert aucun
expert n'est d'accord aujourd'hui c'est
à dire que pour beaucoup notre système
comment vous financez
il y a des réserves vous savez très bien
qu'elle est faite politiquement et dans
l'urgence
du service public si vous vous permettez
de parler mais il y a pas de problème
allez-y par exemple la première la
première mesure elle est fort mais c'est
une vieille toute façon c'est l'égalité
femme homme et là on peut récupérer pas
moins de 8 milliards
est-ce que vous acceptez dans notre
société que une femme soit moi payée
considéré monsieur
je vous promets où on va chercher de
l'argent je t'adore les mesures
et en plus pénalement on ne peut pas
payer donc en payant en plus les femmes
va chercher de l'argent mais j'ai pas il
y a des gens qui disent en Espagne
cotisations
on peut pas comparer ce qui est pas
comparable soyez clair regarde moi pour
trois raisons premièrement parce que je
pense que c'est une façon déguisée de
baisser les retraites parce qu'il y a
beaucoup de chômage des plus de 55 ans
plus personne ne pourra prendre une
retraite à taux plein pour des raisons
physiques ou de chômage et donc c'est
une façon déguisée de dire qu'en fait on
baisse les retraites à taux plein
ensuite il y a pas de consensus sur la
nécessité de la retraite vous dites
comment on finance mais déjà il faudrait
déjà en Suisse ensuite on comprend rien
là pourquoi vous êtes court
je suis hyper concise et c'est
exactement ce qu'on dit il y a pas de
consensus sur la nécessité de cette
réforme c'est super clair les gens ne
sont pas d'accord entre eux pour le
faire et le tout le monde cherche de
l'argent
et le troisième point il y a des façons
de financer qui sont et vous voulez
parce que moi j'aime les gens ici et
pour vous la retraite vous voulez la
retraite
à quel âge moi je veux qu'on reste comme
c'est absolument d'accord
la France est un pays peuplé de gens qui
se la France est un paradis peuplé de
gens qui se croit en enfer voilà Sylvain
Tesson merci Sylvain Tesson il y a un
moment je vous promets allez un tout
petit peu ailleurs aller aux États-Unis
vous voyez des gens de 75 80 ans qui
portent des plateaux comme ça qui porte
des plateaux comme ça justement et Ben
et donc et donc conscience de la chance
que vous avez cette retraite cette
retraite elle est faite cette retraite
elle est faite pour sauver un pays parce
que vous disiez vous ignorez beaucoup de
choses ce pays est surendetté même en
été parfois dans des paysages
répondez-lui je peux [__] deuxième
mesure non mais pas les mesures les
mesures dites lui répondez-lui sur le
truc comme tu dis connait je suis pas
d'accord c'est un choix de société mais
qui dit que la France est un paradis
bien sûr si je t'écoute dans 15 ans on
est l'Argentine mon pote
c'est même pas ça est-ce que tu préfères
de profiter de ta vie
est-ce que tu préfères oui je préfère
profiter de ma vie moi je te parle de
mon cas je te parle le cas des des
ouvriers qui travaillent de nuit déjà
ils sont décalés ils sont ils voient pas
leurs gamins
ils sont flingués ils sont opérés ils
peuvent même pas porter leur petit gamin
j'ai compris
justement mobiliser les 157 milliards
d'euros annuels d'être public aux
entreprises
on peut on a de l'argent deuxième mesure
sans ces aides
contribution des dividendes et les
revenus financiers des entreprises pour
rappel en 2022 les actionnaires des
entreprises du CAC 40 ont touché 80
milliards un sommets jamais jamais
atteints
je vais me faire insulter mais je vais
vous dire quelque chose Monsieur
dites-moi s'il y avait pas comme vous
dites c'est patron du CAC 40 et c'est
milliardaires je l'ai dit l'autre jour
10% des pots des 10% de gens 90% de la
peau ok on va on va dire que je suis un
[__] de pub coloré il engage des
milliers de personnes et ils payent des
impôts en France si tu commences à virer
les Bolloré les Bernard Arnault ces
gens-là on est mort ce sont ces gens là
qui fait en sorte que la France malgré
tout je n'ai pas dit ça chaque personne
qui gagne de l'argent fait envie fait
vivre 9 autres personnes et mais tu dis
quoi alors qu'est-ce que je dis
c'est j'aimerais bien être clair et
concert
le combat j'utilise ce terme
pour que tu comprennes réellement que je
veux revenir
le capital contre le travail
et nous on est dans une logique c'est la
répartition de cette richesse elle est
créée par qui c'est vrai parlons
entrepreneur vous nous dites les les les
grands entreprises ils emploi très bien
mais pour faire des profits mais c'est
un sujet ça c'est du communisme
soviétique bah oui bah si bah si là tu
es en train de me dire que maintenant
tout le monde doit être actionnaire dans
une société pas du tout j'ai pas dit la
répartition de cette richesse
il était plutôt d'accord
et heureusement qu'il y a un équilibre
et les syndicats sont importants au sein
de notre entreprise après 45 si tu pars
si tu pars en vacances si tu pars en
vacances si il y a une retraite sociale
et j'en passe Raymond grâce à ça Raymond
Raymond
un choix de société je vais avoir la vie
vraiment parce que surtout ça Raymond
Raymond c'est pas un mec de télé là-bas
c'est un chauffeur libre
je sais très bien je connais très bien
moi je dis que 50 ans pour moi c'est
l'utopie parce que je peux pas dire à
quelqu'un qui a commencé à 20 ans qui va
arrêter à 50 ça fait que 30 ans moi je
vous dites 62 moi je suis même contre
les 62 je suis pour les 60 moi quand
j'ai commencé à bosser sans cas spécial
j'ai commencé à 16 ans m'avais dit tu
vas être à la retraite à 56 là on
m'annonce 64 c'est pas grave s'il faut y
aller si j'ai la santé j'irai mais je
trouve que c'est scandaleux parce que
c'est toujours les mêmes qui doivent
payer c'est toujours les ouvriers c'est
toujours les petits c'est toujours ceux
qui ont avoir des des métiers de
pénibilité c'est cela qui vont payer par
rapport à des cadres qu'on commençait à
travailler à 30 ans ou à 25 ans par
rapport à un mec un ouvrier et pour
répondre à ta question tout à l'heure tu
disais mon fils
d'Angleterre de de tout arrêter parce
que c'est pas la même imposition pour on
cotise pas la même chose nous on a fait
des coupes des coupes sur l'enseignement
sur les la sur les pompiers sur la
police on découpe sur tous les budgets
on paye l'essence plein pot on paye les
radars sur les routes on paye les
cigarettes allez voir dans les autres
pays s'ils ont ça
malgré tout ça on est quand même obligé
de dire aux gens faut aller travailler
plus tard
vous avez vu ça ailleurs on est le pays
le plus imposable au monde pourquoi
de l'oseille ils font quoi que l'argent
qu'on leur donne
la question fiscal sur deux en France
n'est pas imposable tu as compris ça à
notre sujet
mais le pays qui paye le plus d'impôts
les Allemands payent moins de charge
patronales que les Français le travail
en Allemagne et moins cher en Espagne
c'est moins cher tout est moins cher
partout dans le monde tout est moins
cher
je vais mettre juste je mets juste à la
place je vais mettre juste à la place
non mais c'est surtout ça il faut juste
se mettre à un moment à la place d'un
ouvrier moi je
nombreux pots ouvriers à 18h à 6h30 du
matin les gars non mais il y a plus de
côté il se réveille à 6h30 on peut même
peut-être plus tôt parfois 6 enfants ils
partent ils partent de chez eux à 6h30
c'est pas ça il parle de chez eux à 6h30
s'il vous plaît le midi il mange entre
eux une gamelle pendant une heure le
soir il travaille jusqu'à 17h30 il
rentre chez eux ils sont cuits le mec
qui a travaillé à 20 ans bon rendez
compte ou pas au-delà il va devoir
travailler jusqu'à 63 ans d'accord 63
celui qui a 43 64
sur les toits même à quel moment à quel
moment ce gars-là vit un moment parce
que ne croyez pas il travaille de 6h30
du matin jusqu'à 18h30 ce qui rentre
chez le soir et c'est des mecs
travaillent souvent loin à 18h30 19h ils
ont ils ont du mal à s'en sortir parce
que le 10 du mois ils sont en galère je
les vois tous hein donc et donc voilà
donc ça veut dire que le mec n'a jamais
de kiff dans la vie il n'a pas fait que
sa vie à survivre à survivre à survivre
non mais
un moment est-ce qu'il y a pas un moyen
de et je dis pas au cas par cas c'est
impossible mais
de trouver par Corporation peut-être
un moment un moment un moment tous les
Français tous les français et tous les
métiers et toutes les et tous les
ouvriers un ouvrier les mecs il a pas la
même que moi je suis désolé bien sûr
voilà les gars donc je suis désolé moi
bien sûr 64 ans 70 ans 75 ans même s'ils
veulent mais un ouvrier moi je vois je
vous dis j'ai mes potes ouvriers un
avant tout je pense à eux parce que ils
ont ils avaient dire que toutes leurs
vies ils ont passé c'est une vie de
galère je suis désolé les mecs moi t'es
pas là t'es pas là sur terre et tu es
pas en France pour vivre ça une vie de
galère je suis désolé donc à un moment
peut-être qu'il faut travailler un petit
peu plus sur ce projet et peut-être dire
et ben on va faire par Corporation on va
essayer de trouver des désaménagements
tu ne peux pas faire le seul régime
qu'ils ont regardé celui des des
policiers tu veux que je te dise mais je
vais dire un truc moi
que tu as fait mais pourquoi pas 50 ans